nous sommes à l'islature un petit écart
sur la route de silaos et qui fait
partie de la commune de Saint-Louis au
bien sûr ce n'est pas un pollueurbain
mais plutôt un petit coin où il fait bon
vivre au milieu d'une nature sauvage
mais ses habitants connaissent-ils
l'origine du nom de leur il est nous
allons tout de suite leur poser la
question
c'était qui sursis vous savez longtemps
l'isle-sur-si tient son nom d'un
singulier personnel
nous sommes en 1817 plus de 30 ans avant
l'abolition de l'esclavage
le surlory reçoit un courrier de Furcy
son esclave lui réclamance sa liberté
jamais encore un esclave n'avait pas
signé son maître en justice
il se trouve que Furci est né d'une mère
indienne affranchi en 1789 après un
séjour en France sa soeur constance née
d'un homme libre et racheté par son père
Furci lui restait esclave à 31 ans il
tente donc de briser ses chaînes du fait
de ses origines furcit se considère
comme un homme libre et souhaite quitter
monsieur Lorie qui par confiance la
placer à la tête de sa maison
on imagine le scandale à l'époque
pourtant contre tous le procureur
général Gilbert boucher défendra le
dossier jusqu'au bout il accordera même
sa protection au marron malgré tout
recherchée puis arrêter et détenu
dans la capitale l'affaire fait grand
bruit en défendant les doctrines de
fursi le révolutionnaire bouché et son
allié Sully Brunet ouvre une brèche la
liberté de quelques 15.000 individus
Brunet d'origine malgache est attaché
aux gens de couleur il est finalement
suspendu et par vivre à Saint-Benoît
Gilbert boucher lui sous la pression
quittera la Réunion quant à Furci il
n'obtiendra jamais sa liberté